so we have a property about so we have
probably about symmetry the next
property I've called dissection okay
I'll give you the algebra and then I'll
ask you to help me understand why have I
called it this if you have an integral
from A to B a single integral you can
express it as two separate integrals you
can break it into two pieces and there's
lots of ways you can break it but the
particular this property is about is I
can change the boundaries let's just say
I have another value in between a and B
called cape if I integrate our from a to
K part way then I can take over and do
the integral from K to be and do the
same function okay so what would this
look like let's just go with this x
squared example that we just drew up
over here so if I said let's make a and
B out of there
zero and four so wrong color so what is
this saying if I went from zero to four
I could take this whole area zero to
four and treat it as one integral like
here on the left hand side or if I want
to I could slice it into pieces and say
well look I'm just gonna do this part up
here excuse me from zero say there - huh
no that's good video halfway point
doesn't have to be halfway could be from
zero to three if I want it and then I
could take over here
later on and dissect my area into two
pieces okay now why is this useful
well sometimes particular values are
really nice and convenient to put into a
particular function it just depends on
what the function is okay and secondly
sometimes in solving a problem you end
up with multiple integrals lots and lots
of long string of them and you're like
this is a key is this some way I could
do less integration well it's sort of
like it's almost like collecting like
terms do you sort of see that right it's
like same function same function just
four boundaries so long as those
boundaries connect in fact I'm going to
highlight that so long as there is a
continuity between the two intervals is
what we call them you can combine them
into a single integral question yep
yeah you absolutely could so what Eric
was just suggesting was if I have some
other area like this if I wanted to go
say fro let's call that five from zero
to two and four to five right you can
see cuz it's just areas it's just shapes
right what I could do if I wanted is
workout zero to five and then take away
the green piece which is the part I
don't want just take away two to four
that would be fine
these are just shapes they're kind of
like composite figures if you remember
them back from life you're eight and
unite okay and you can chop and change
them however you please okay so long as
you use the right numbers okay so that
was dissection all right two more for
you okay so you're doing well this next
one here is a weird one oops don't you
think you Sunda okay what I want to
think about is at the moment we have
only considered integration in a
particular direction namely from left to
right from left to right so all along
this whole time we sort of assumed that
this number is smaller than this number
that make sense like you go from zero to
four or five to eight or something like
that so you're progressing from left to
right what would happen if I went in the
opposite direction what would happen if
I integrated in the reverse direction
well let's think about this and we'll go
all the way back to our fundamental
theorem of calculus what does this thing
equal to in terms of its primitives well
the regular calculus definition of this
is the primitive of the
top value take away the primitive of the
bottom value do you remember that F of
we usually would say be take away F off
we would usually say hey and that's the
premium of course capital F right but
what I've done is I've um I've swapped
my variables I've swapped my boundaries
in their order so this is not going to
be B and a anymore this is not my
endpoint there's not much that point
I've switched them so this is now going
to be a over here and B over here now
how is this related to my regular normal
integral that I've been using all the
way along here well isn't it your
regular interval your relat relat
integral I could say I should say but
I'm in opposite order like if I took a
minus sign at the front that will switch
these two around back the way they're
supposed to be right it'll be something
like this yeah are you with me I've just
factored out a negative sign but I know
what this thing is by definition this is
my normal integral right by definition
this is from A to B in my normal order
does that make sense so this is kind of
weird and strange because just like
integration now takes into account hey
if you're above or below now your area
is something different it's negative
well this is now saying actually not
just is the position of it different
depending on which way you think about
the area from left to right versus right
to left you get a different answer at
the bottom okay now I want you to think
back to our original metaphor which will
help you understand this okay
think back to the picture we drew that
Russell helped us with what was the
illustration I gave you
there's the astronaut right now we
imagine the astronaut traveling through
space and trying to work out their total
distance and I said something like I'm
trying to member off the top my head
we'd said something like what's the
difference from time one to time three
off and what we have was speed right we
had their speed so let me give it a name
let's call it V for velocity right so
that velocity function that's what we
integrate
right you rember and then we've got
displacement so this is from our one to
our three and then we came up with some
number I know I haven't 60 or something
like that well what would it mean for
the astronaut what is the different
situation if I said let's actually
reverse our boundaries what would this
mean for the problem well you're not
comparing styling for our one to our
three you're going together this you're
going backwards in time does this make
sense your time traveling from don't
think about you know the start to the
end think as if you started at the end
and now you come back well you're not
going to be 160 kilometers forward right
you're going to be 160 kilometers behind
because you've just traveled back in
time does that make sense so actually we
need this idea of of negativeness not
just here with sine areas but also here
with the direction that you're
integrating okay